[Music]
good morning and welcome to trevor
phillips on sunday
tomorrow was billed as freedom day
nearly all coronavirus restrictions in
england
are supposed to be lifted at midnight
tonight but based on the last 24
hours it'd be a brave person who
predicts exactly where they'll be
and what they'll be doing this time
tomorrow
ironically the one person who does know
where he'll be is the health secretary
he won't be getting on the bus to work
he's holed up in the back bedroom after
testing positive
the prime minister though won't be
isolating beside despite being a contact
he'll be participating in a test and
release trial
but that won't apply to potentially
millions of others
with cases going up sharply many people
may wonder if it's not just a branding
around freedom day that needs to change
but the policy the previously
irreversible boris johnson may not
quite be reaching for reverse gear yet
but how long will that resolve last
well in just a few minutes i'll be
putting that question to local
government secretary
robert generic we'll be getting the
labor view with shadow health secretary
jonathan
ashworth social care is a major issue in
the government's entree
former first secretary damian greene
reckons he has a potential solution
and he'll be telling us about that it's
nelson mandela day
we'll be speaking to the great man's
daughter doctor makazui
mandela and we'll be looking at
interesting results from a poll of
business leaders
speaking to chartered management
institute boss anne
frank but first the
original plan was for us to be joined
this morning by sajid javid but after
the health secretary tested positive
a last-minute substitution was made and
his colleague robert generic
the local government secretary has come
off the bench he joins us
from birmingham thank you for joining us
in place of your colleague this morning
mr generic who despite being uh
tested positive uh for covert is uh
is now self-isolating um let me just
ask you this we just got the statement
uh a few minutes ago
uh about the prime minister's situation
he says it says that
the prime minister and chancellor will
be participating in the daily contact
testing pilot
to allow them to continue work from
downing street
now um when the prime minister talked
about
freedom day did he just mean freedom for
him and the chancellor
and other cabinet colleagues and not for
the
millions who are supposed to go to work
but won't be
having access to that pilot
well good morning trevor thanks for
having me on the program again
you're right to say that the prime
minister and the chancellor
were contacted by nhs track and trace
overnight which shows that the system is
working they're going to take part
in a daily testing pilot which is
available to a range of organizations
not just to
politicians it's being used by border
force
and by the transport for london that
runs the tube in london
for example and that means that they can
conduct
important government business but they
won't be able to go out socializing or
or meet other friends and family so
they'll have to limit
their their contact with other people as
much as they possibly can
but to your broader point we do believe
that we're able to move forward
tomorrow with stage four of the road map
that's really for two principal reasons
the prime minister set
two ambitious targets earlier in the
year firstly that we wanted to ensure
that two-thirds of the adult population
of the country
had been double vaccinated by this point
and secondly and just as importantly
that every adult in the whole of the
united kingdom
had been offered at least one
vaccination and both of those tests
have been met so that does mean that
we're able to move forward but we'll be
doing so very cautiously
trevor because as you note cases are
rising
hospitalizations are rising and so we're
all going to have to exercise
personal responsibility and informed
good judgment
in the days ahead can i just bring you
back
mr generic to the question i asked you
which is
uh about this pilot which uh
the chancellor and the prime minister
are part of and as i understand it
uh mr gove when he had a similar problem
a little while ago suddenly also found
himself part of a pilot
now these pilots are supposed to be
random um is there a cabinet minister
who won't have the luck to be a
subject in this pilot if he or she
suffers is pinged
well this is a pilot as i said that's
being
piloted by around 20 organizations
within the public sector
including border force including
transport for london
it's correct that the cabinet office and
downing street are part of the pilot
i'm not aware that other government
departments are
it means that you can be tested every
day
in specialist asymptomatic testing
centers such as the one
that's been set up in downing street it
means that the prime minister and the
chancellor will be able to conduct
the most essential government meetings
but the rest of their time
will be have to be spent isolating and
not uh as i say meeting up with
family or friends or socializing in any
other way so it's relatively
restricted thank you for the i entirely
appreciate your point trevor
that this isn't available yet to wider
members of the public
and i appreciate the frustration that
they might feel listening to this
they like me or other members of the
public who are pinged
will have to self-isolate in the usual
way and that's a really important part
of our plan to keep covid under control
okay
to be i i get i i get that and i
appreciate you just said that
if you were pinged you'd have to
self-isolate but there's no evidence
that that's what happens
you can see what it looks like it looks
like one rule for them
and one rule for the rest of us
well as i say this is this is a pilot
that's actually being used by
around 20 organizations so hundreds if
not thousands of
uh public sector staff who work in those
organizations will be able to use this
pilot we'll be learning from it and of
course if it's possible to roll it out
more broadly because it's proven to be
safe and successful
then we will do but for the rest of us
who are not yet part of that pilot
the crucial advice is if you are
contacted by nhs tests and trace to take
that very seriously and
to self-isolate because although it can
be frustrating
that has helped us to prevent thousands
of cases a study from the end of last
year
showed that test and trace had prevented
six hundred thousand
cases and eight thousand unnecessary
deaths
in just a three month period leading up
to the end of last year so it is an
important
tool in our armory to tackle the virus
right now one last point on this if i
may
um do you happen to know who decided
that downing street
would be on that list
no i don't know trevor but as i say it
is just one of several
large organizations uh some much larger
like border force and tfl that employ
many thousands of public sector
employees if the pilot is proven to be
safe and successful then i'm sure it
will inform
steps that will be available to the
wider public and remember of course
that within six weeks we do anticipate
self-isolation changing so in mid-august
the plan at the moment is that those
people who are double vaccinated and by
then it will be the overwhelming
majority of the population
won't need to self-isolate in the same
way that they do today
and from tomorrow the school bubble
system
will be retired and so that will also
make it easier
for members of the public i appreciate
it's been very difficult very
challenging indeed
for many schools in recent weeks
particularly the last fortnight where
the number of young people
uh having to self-isolate as a result of
bubbles and nhs testing trace has been
considerable
that will improve from next week we'll
then go into the school holidays
and for mid-august we anticipate we'll
be able to move forward
for the double vaccinated to a different
system
i want to come to vaccination of
children
in a moment but let's um follow what
you've just said last week half a
million people
were pinged uh estimates uh out this
morning suggest that up to 10
million people might be pinged in the
coming
weeks is what you've just told me that
the government is clearly heading
towards a situation
in which fewer people are likely to be
paying the or that we might
lift self-isolation the self-isolation
regime
for example as the former prime minister
tony blair suggests this morning
that people who are double-jabbed would
not have to self-isolate
is that what's in prospect in next month
yes it is we've already said that we
want to get to a point by
the middle of august whereby those
people who've been double vaccinated
wouldn't have to self-isolate in the
same way they would take
tests and have to follow all of the
testing requirements
but they wouldn't need to self-isolate
in the same way and that will be a
significant step forward
the reason that we've chosen to wait
until
mid-august is to ensure that we get even
more people
double vaccinated because we know with
the delta variant
that one vaccine is good protection
but two vaccines is very significantly
better
in preventing both transmission and
serious illness
and death and so by waiting that extra
six weeks
we should get to the point where a very
significant number of additional people
particularly the younger people in their
uh
late teens and 20s who have been later
to the vaccine program
have been double vaccinated myself for
example i've got my appointment
uh next week to be getting my second
vaccine
and so by waiting a bit longer we get
much more of the population into
that category that is the decision that
we've chosen to make obviously we'll
keep that under
review but we expect by the middle of
the month to be moving to a somewhat
different system which will be
less restrictive and easier for people
to manage but i do appreciate
that this is proving to be very
challenging obviously for schools
although they are about to go into the
school holidays
but particularly for businesses and
public services across the country
everybody understands that the
government is trying to make a judgment
between the progress of vaccination
and the speed of and variation in the
virus and it's a hard judgment to make
but let's test this out a little bit
let's start with
the issue of people who have been double
jabs like the health secretary
who have now contracted covid
what percentage of people currently in
hospital with kovid
have been double jabs do you know don't
have those
figures trevor but what what the health
sector's case does
highlight is the fact that although the
current set of approved vaccines
are very good at helping people
to avoid serious illness and there's no
full safe
vaccine that can provide you with 100
protection what the current vaccines do
is ensure
between 80 and 90 percent improvement
in the likelihood of getting serious
illness and
even greater improvement in the
likelihood of death so
they take what is a otherwise a very
nasty
disease which can lead to serious
illness and death
and turn it into something that the
overwhelming majority of us
should be able to withstand but they
don't provide 100
protection and that's why i say again
despite the fact we're moving into the
next phase of the virus and it's
right to do so we will need to do so
with great caution
and each of us particularly the most
vulnerable continue to show
personal responsibility and judgment in
protecting ourselves
our loved ones and the wider public i
get that but let's just
get clear on what basis you're making
these judgments
not very long ago on this program the
former health secretary
matthew hancock told us that the
majority or the vast
majority i think overwhelming i think is
what he used majority of people
who are hospitalized were not double jab
what he suggested
to me was that actually being fully
vaccinated
provided pretty much complete protection
against the virus recurring
or being passed on is that still
the case it is still the case
the being vaccinated with our current
set of vaccines
provides you as i said earlier but with
between 80 and 90 percent
protection still the case why not let
people who are double jabbed
uh be exempted from self-isolation
i'm sorry i didn't hear that that
question trevor there's quite a lot of
background noise
if if it is still if what mr hancock
said is still the case
why are you not exempting people
who are double jabbed from
self-isolation
given the economic and problems
and the chaos frankly that the amount of
pinging that's going to take place
will cause this country
well we've chosen to wait a short period
six weeks
on medical advice which is to ensure
that even more of the population
get double vaccinated that that has two
effects of course there's a question of
fairness
because that ensures that younger people
can be double vaccinated before
something is opened up to those who are
more fortunate and have been able to be
vaccinated sooner because they were
older or more vulnerable it also means
that by having more people
double vaccinated transmission will be
reduced within wider society because of
course a vaccine doesn't just protect
yourself
it helps to a lesser extent but
nonetheless an important extent
to protect other people by reducing the
risk of transmission
so it was a precautionary step i
appreciate that
but one that we took on the basis of the
medical and scientific advice that by
the middle of august
we'd be in the position where a much
larger number of individuals
particularly amongst
those in their 20s who statistically are
more likely to be out socializing
meeting other people more regularly more
of those individuals will be double
vaccinated i think that's the right
thing to do
but i do appreciate that it will produce
some further
disruption and frustration in the coming
weeks but i would
again urge people to ensure that they do
have the nhs
the app on their phones that it's fully
switched on we're seeing actually more
people downloading
the app than ever before so the evidence
is positive
but then if you do get contacted by
track and trace of course to follow all
the steps that are required because it
is a really important
part of our our toolkit for tackling the
virus at this
critical stage as cases are still rising
hospitalizations are increasing and we
won't really expect
this uh wave of the virus to peak
until late august maybe even early
september so
there are going to be some quite
challenging weeks ahead
mr generic um two points first of all
you've been clear that actually there's
a lot of stuff we don't there a lot of
things we don't know
we can't be certain about and everybody
knows that secondly
you've used the word caution or
precautionary i think now half a dozen
times i've been noting it
during this interview why are we still
going ahead
with freedom day tomorrow
well as the prime minister said earlier
in the week there's no easy
or straightforward answer to the
question of
when we should move forwards and move
from a system
of legal requirements to one of personal
responsibility but now does seem like
the logical time
we're moving into the summer holidays
for school
which will mean there'll be less
transmission amongst young people and
families
the weather is good and so that is the
most benign climate
for tackling the virus and we modeled
what might happen if we were to delay
for another short period
for example till september and there
wasn't a compelling case
to do so so now does seem like the right
time to move forward
but we have to be honest with the public
that cases are rising
as i say we haven't yet reached the peak
of this wave
of infection and so we all do need to
approach this
carefully and cautiously and in a
gradual
way and we will all need to exercise
good judgment
we are moving from that time where the
state told you what to do
things were mandated as a matter of law
to one which had to come at some point
where we trusted people we trusted
businesses and organizations
and gave them the information they
needed to make good judgments
all right um can i just say can i just
be frank and say
i understand all of that but i think
that
some people will feel that what you're
really saying
is that the government is essentially
being
blown by the course of events rather
than having a plan
now there could be some very specific
things that you could
say we're definitely going to do for
example you could decide as have several
other countries united states and israel
to vaccinate children and that would
make sure
that we reduce the circulation of the
virus
and the possibility of more variant why
not well firstly trevor
we do have a plan and that plan
fortunately is working
we set out that we would vaccinate by
this point
in fact we've done it earlier than we
said we would do two-thirds of the adult
population with two jabs
we said that we would ensure every adult
in the whole united kingdom
is offered let's ask you about children
we've managed to achieve both of those
two things
i've just asked you about children
rather than adults i wonder if we could
deal with that
understood now that we have offered the
jab to all adults and of course there
are still some that need to come forward
i'd strongly urge them to do so
we will be taking advice in the coming
days
from the jcvi we haven't yet received
their final advice
on whether to extend the vaccine roll
out to children
that seems like a sensible thing to do
and so
we will be looking carefully at their
advice when we receive it we expect it
very soon
on whether or not we should open up the
vaccine program
in the first instance to those children
who are just
short of their 18th birthday to those
children who have particular
vulnerabilities
and those children who are in households
where there are people who are
particularly
vulnerable that seems like a sensible
way for us to proceed
but ministers will need to make that
decision when they're armed with the
final advice
from the jcvr jcvi our expert advisors
and as i said i expect that we will be
receiving that advice
very soon okay uh mr before we finish
can i um ask you to
to uh return to your normal position uh
on the pitch in
in the team and that is as uh local
government minister
uh you are one of the two secretaries of
state responsible for social care
the prime minister said on the steps of
downing street
on the moment he became prime minister
that
the government had a plan prepared
which it would reveal for social care
he will become uh he will have hit two
years as prime minister
in the next few weeks when are we going
to see that plan
that was prepared two years ago
well the prime minister intends to honor
that commitment we've said that we're
going to bring forward a plan
before the end of the year and i expect
it will be published much sooner than
that
we're working intensively on it as local
government secretary of course i
play a role in that also the health
secretary and the chancellor so you
won't have to wait
very much longer as local government
secretary i know how incredibly
important it is that we put the
financing
of social care on a sustainable footing
it's been tested
very severely over the course of the
last 15 months people who work in the
sector have done an absolutely
magnificent
job as have local councils in keeping it
going
but now is the moment where we need to
map out how we have a long-term
sustainable future for social care that
protects the elderly and the most
vulnerable in society
and ensures that people do not have to
lose their homes and that the people who
work in the sector
get looked after as well
for the prime minister to set out his
proposals when you say
when you say before the end of the year
did you mean the end of the calendar
year which would be two and a half
years since the prime minister made his
pledge or before the end of the
this parliamentary the end the
parliamentary set recess which at least
would just be two years
[Applause]
well parliament goes into races in a
couple of days time
we've said in the past that we would be
bringing forward the proposals before
the end of this calendar year
but i believe we will be in a position
to set out proposals much sooner than
that
but if i'm afraid you just have to wait
a little bit longer all i can say to you
is that all of us who are involved in
this care very much about it
i think it's one of the most important
generational issues that we have to
tackle as a country
and we'll be publishing proposals soon
mr generic thank you you know what a
patient person i am obviously
not everybody is as patient as me we'll
see when that uh
plan arrives thank you very much for
your time
thank you
robert generic there well let's get some
reaction to what we've just heard
from labour's shadow health secretary
jonathan
ashworth who joins us now
um mr ashworth uh
do you think that uh rob generic has a
case that
the uh chancellor and the prime minister
are they've been pinged and they
basically just have to do what they're
told
um and it's just
i unfortunate there'll be parents across
the country
who have struggled this past year when
their
children have been sent home because
they were in a bubble and had to isolate
there will be workers across the country
who have to isolate
when pinged including in public services
like the nhs
and i think for many of them waking up
this morning to hear that
there is a special rule an exclusive
rule for boris johnson
and rishi sunak they will be saying to
themselves
that this looks like one rule for them
and something else
for the rest of us nobody understands
how you can get
access to this special special treatment
this special vip lane
where you don't have to isolate yourself
if it is a pilot
why can't employers apply for the
workforce to be
members of this pilot why can't schools
have applied to be part of this
pilot test i really do think a lot of
people are going to be looking at this
and thinking
what on earth is going on and of course
this is a time when we need to maintain
confidence in the isolation policies
because isolation taking yourself away
from society
if you've been in contact with someone
who's got the virus is one of the key
ways in which we break transmission
and of course we know that infections
are rising at the moment
let's be uh fair here
if it were sakir stama in number 10
and you were the health secretary you
would be coming on here and saying
look the man is the prime minister of
course
we have to take special steps because uh
he runs the country and we can't have
the prime minister
uh inhibited from doing his job
i'm not sure how the prime minister
joining zoom calls from his office
in the flat above downing street
inhibits him doing his job to be frank
he's still able to use the telephone
he's still able to use
a computer and he's still able to join a
zoom call as
lots of us have had to do in these past
16 months
throughout the crisis i think why it
sticks in people's throat is that
apparently there is this special system
this vip system that you
that somehow some people can get on get
onto where they can avoid
isolating if they've been pinged now if
there is this system
then other people should be able to
apply for it other employers should be
able to apply for it and ask for their
workforce to be considered that's not
the case at the moment so for
so it looks like for a lot of us it is
indeed one rule for
them at the top and another for the rest
of us
okay well let's just talk about the
actual policy rather than the politics
of
this morning um there are a number of
things which are in the air
for example the proposal for test and
release
a version of it supported by your former
leader tony blair this morning i.e
that people who can can be tested every
day
and if they're negative they can get on
with their
jobs would you support that
being applied across the population
well sage are looking at it and i think
we should wait and see
for the sage final analysis of it of
course the problem with people getting
pings the problem with people being
asked to isolate is that is a symptom
of increased transmission in society now
we know that we've had over 50 000
cases we know that the virus is climbing
again very
steeply so what you've got to do is put
in
measures put measures in place to break
transmission chains
but instead of doing that we're about to
have freedom day
tomorrow where the government where
sajid javid and others are effectively
putting their foot down on the
accelerator
and throwing off the seat belts because
precautionary measures
like mask wearing like encouraging
people to work from home like paying
people decent sick pay
and are not being implemented i think
that is a mistake
so let's get this clear so when you and
other labour spokespeople have been
saying
for the last two or three weeks you
don't oppose freedom day
what you really meant was that you do
oppose opening up on tomorrow
no we want to proceed with caution and i
would have
an approach which is about protecting
tomorrow then
just to be clear what would you not do
tomorrow do not do tomorrow
well i would not get rid of the monetary
mass wearing look
people want people will want to do the
right thing and they'll want to wear
masks
but they want to be reassured that in
return that they are protected by others
wearing masks
but getting rid of the mandatory rule i
think is too much of a risk
tomorrow we're likely to see possibly
the busiest day on the transport
networks
for 16 months with people going back to
work i would say allow people to
continue to work from home
if they want to i would say let's let's
mobilize british manufacturing
to build air filtration units to put in
our schools and our premises
i would pay people sick pay and i would
prepare for the future
by investing in the national health
service now and because
we know come the winter mr ashworth
everything you've just said is pretty
much
what conservative ministers come on here
and say so other than
moving from mandatory mask wearing to
voluntary mask wearing which surveys in
the last few days
show us that i think three quarters
maybe more of people will do
anyway that's the difference between you
and the government
no and with respect i don't think it i
haven't seen conservative ministers
coming on the newspaper let me assure
you
you obviously haven't watched a program
but that's what they've been saying
pretty much what you've just said
they don't talk about sick pay they
don't say they're going to fix sick pay
they don't say they're going to give
people the right to work from home
should they want to work from home they
don't say they're going to use british
manufacturing
to build air filtration systems to put
them into schools
and they're certainly not preparing the
future by investing in the nhs
or indeed looking at our testing
capacity and seeing if we can invest in
our testing capacity
to start testing for flu and other
respiratory viruses
this winter as well so there is actually
a difference between the labour party
and the conservative party of course our
proposals are backed up by sage
and indeed are backed up by a report
from the academy of medical sciences
last week the government's proposal is
to
is to just go full long into this
headlong into this throwing
a freedom day throwing off all
restrictions
that risks increased pressures on the
nhs and we're already seeing cancer
operations
cancelled even a liver transplant
operations cancelled
in birmingham i think it was but it also
risks
a new variant because when you have a
pool of infections
in society and increasing an increasing
level of infection
and you have a partially vaccinated
population
you're putting a selection pressure on
the virus to mutate
and the big risk is we could snatch
defeat from the jaws of victory if you
like
and be set back set back and the vicious
cycle starts all over again
all right um i just want to keep seeing
you know what the labour party were in
government
would do differently um one other area
of policy where you might do something
different is on the uh
the pandemic if you like the pingocracy
um
there are those who say that we should
just drop the app
or that we should essentially tweak it
your former leader says this morning
that actually we need to adjust it so
fewer people
are pinged would you have it
desensitized or dropped
well again the problem with the pinging
isn't the thing in itself
it's a that is a symptom of transmission
in society
and infection rates are increasing which
is why we would put in place
those containment measures to slow the
spread
of the virus and that is a material
difference between us and the government
we would also by the way do more to
drive up vaccination rates amongst
younger people because we really need to
get younger people
uh to take part to take the vaccine and
of course
we would ask the speculation is the jcvi
are not going to propose
uh vaccination for adolescents we're
doing that in other countries
or they are doing it in other countries
in the united states and
in parts of europe and so on if that is
the advice from the jcpi then i suppose
that is the advice but i would really
ask them
to carefully consider whether or not we
should be vaccinating
uh teenage children in this country we
need to take another
a number of measures to really drive
infection rates down
to stop people catching the virus and
stop people being contacts of those
with the virus so just very briefly you
you are against vaccinating children
no no no i'm not against vaccinating
children i think it needs to be looked
at by
the jcpi if other countries are doing it
i don't understand why
we're not proposing it but of course in
the end these are always clinical
decisions
but if the jcvi are going to propose
tomorrow that
that we are that we should not vaccinate
children i hope they can fully explain
their thinking and why they've taken a
different decision to the united
states for example thank you very much
mr ashworth
okay we spoke earlier in the show
briefly about social care one of the
major issues that the government's
grappling with we're approaching boris
johnson's two-year anniversary
as i said a moment ago which means it's
almost two
also two years since he placed to fix
the problem once and for all
but unless we've all missed the memo no
plan has actually emerged so
others have stepped in to fill the void
and one of those is damien green the
former deputy prime minister
who's backing a new plan announced today
mr greene
joins us now um
damian green just before we get on to
your plan on social care
can i just ask you ashford which is your
constituency is uh
the main station on the way to france if
you're going by train
are you convinced that the quarantine
requirement uh
about france uh even for people who are
double jab
is absolutely necessary um
i i can see the reasons for it and and
sadly uh we're not the main stop at the
moment because
eurostar traffic is down so much that
they're
they're only running services uh from
london at the moment so it has no direct
effect
uh on my constituency what will have an
effect is uh getting
travel back uh as normally as fast as
possible so they can
reopen their full services but it's part
of a general point isn't
it that actually the balance between
uh what the local government secret
uh described as caution or being
precautionary
and uh getting the economy going
again uh has the government got this
right do you think um i i i mean i
i think the the the french decision uh
is is reasonable um i think
you know sometimes when you have to take
decisions quickly shortly before they
come into effect
um that causes uh problems for people
um but i think the this this sort of old
debate about the balance between the
economy
and infections is a slightly false one
in that what we all want or particularly
what business wants is some kind of
certainty that
when you take an unlocking step uh that
that
you're not going to reverse that later
on and what we've learned throughout
this pandemic
is that a degree of caution for a time
is worth it
because that makes it easier uh
and more sensible to unlock permanently
uh for the future um but you know we're
as
everyone says we're not out of the woods
yet there is the infections are rising
as
they're expected to do um i i think it
is a good idea to continue with with
uh with monday's unlocking because as
chris whittie said if not now when this
is
this is the best time of year uh to do
that um but
yeah nobody should think we're on um as
a one-way path to
to unlocking if if we don't all continue
to behave responsibly
okay let's talk about your proposals in
relation to
social care what is different from what
you want to do
uh in what you want to do from what uh
sir andrew dilnut proposed
that set a cap for example on what we'd
each have to spend at about fifty
thousand pounds
the the big difference in in this report
uh from public policy projects
is that instead of having a flat cap of
of say 50 000 pounds
uh we suggest that it should be a
percentage of your assets now
for most people's assets that's that's
broadly speaking their house
and the reason why having a flat number
is
is difficult to implement it's why the
de la proposal has never been
implemented
is that it has widely different effects
in different parts of the country
in parts of the country where house
prices are much lower
than 50 000 pounds will take a
significant chunk
out of your estate in other parts of the
country it won't
so it's geographically unfair if you
just have a flat number
if you have a percentage figure say that
you can wherever you are in the country
keep 70 of your assets we think that's
fairer
and therefore more politically palatable
for a decision
which is going to be difficult whatever
means you try and raise the money it's
difficult
because people are going to have to pay
more than we have done in the past
because the social care system is
underfunded to the tune of
something between 7 and 10 billion a
year so
first point to be clear you are now
essentially accepting that in order to
fund social care
people are going to have to sell their
homes no i'm not absolutely not that
that's the whole point because if you
can
uh keep a measurable percentage of your
assets and you won't have to sell your
home
you can buy an insurance policy or
something like that maybe
using features like equity release so
that you can actually
use use the value of your home but not
have to sell it
and i think the difference between the
ppp proposal and the dildo proposal
is that everyone will know that one of
the examples we use in the report is 70
percent
that 70 percent of their inheritance if
you like is
is guaranteed for their children or
their family
whereas under dill not the percentage
that you might be able to pass on
is wildly different in different parts
of the country
well let's just examine this point about
fairness
and i wonder if you could exp explain it
for us because
the average london householder under
your proposals would still have
whether they take out insurance or they
borrow whatever it is
they'd still have 337 000 pounds in the
kitty
after hitting your your proposed cap
compared to someone in the northeast
who'd have just 92 000 pounds and
someone in your own constituency ashford
would be left with 140 000. uh how is
that
fairer yeah well i did the calculations
on the basis of of ashford versus
hartlepool and in in my constituency
the average house price is 370 000 in
hartley pool it's 130 000.
if you have a 50 60 70 000 pound cap all
the sort of figures have been
mentioned uh then in hartlepool you're
losing
more than half your inheritance um in
ashford you're losing a much smaller
proportion
and you're still left with a lot more
actual
money well but because you know for the
the way
the housing system works uh and there's
a whole
other argument to be had about planning
um but the way the housing system works
it just means you are
when you're alive you have a lot more
wealth you have a lot more asset
just because the same house in different
parts of the country
is worth different things now to solve
that requires a lot of change about
planning and indeed leveling up so that
uh house prices go up in other parts of
the country because they become
uh in places where people want to move
to but that's that's a longer term thing
in the meantime what what you can do now
is to say wherever you are in the
country
you get to keep the same percentage of
your assets
so that you know you will know you know
roughly what your house is worth and
therefore
if you're thinking about you know what
can i leave uh to my children
then you will know that you've got the
the bulk of that
uh to leave um you've been in number 10
for quite some time as deputy prime
minister you were
a minister in other departments has the
prime minister made the right judgment
today uh to work from number 10 under
this pilot scheme to which it appears
every cabinet minister
has access and hardly anybody else does
well it's not clear who's got access to
it but yeah i mean i think the
in practical terms allowing the prime
minister and the chancellor of exchequer
to work as normally as possible
is actually quite sensible and and i
hope one of the effects of this
is to accelerate uh the
the pilot scheme and indeed the analysis
of the pilot scheme because this might
be
a way out of uh the current problems of
people not being able to
uh go to work i think the sooner we get
to that uh the better and and
clearly daily testing is one way to
achieve that
so i you know i'd be very keen if we
could move to a system where
uh if you if you have been in contact
with someone um but you're showing no
symptoms
and as far as you know you haven't got
it uh then
regular testing should replace isolation
i think that would that would be a
significant
unlocking step uh and it would be very
welcome
damon green thank you very much indeed
thank you
now we all know that the pandemic has
changed the labor market furlough
working from home
and unfortunately job losses but what's
received less attention is how many
people
who have kept their job have seen their
working conditions altered
many say against their will now a
campaign is underway to clamp down
on so-called fire and re-hire the
process of forcing workers onto worse
terms and conditions this week we've
been investigating the issue
amina patel is a social care worker in
tower hamlets in east london
for the last three years she's been
employed by the council to look after
elderly members of her community
but last july her contract at work was
changed
an active member of her local trade
union amina says that she and her
colleagues are victims of a growing
trend amongst employers
known as fire and rehire these contracts
that have been imposed make us workers
worse off the main thing with the
contracts in tower hamlets
is a reduction in severance by 80
percent
um cuts to travel allowance for myself
i'm a low-paid worker
so for me that's a reduction of 596
pounds to my salary
makes you feel disrespected i think
that's the biggest part
we were you know so many of us in the
council like myself we've been we've
been key workers we're essential workers
we've been working from home going out
doing visits you know where we
absolutely have to
wearing the necessary ppe
but then at the same time you know
you've got people clapping on thursdays
and you've got the council clapping
but then you're being fired and rehired
and being put on worse contracts that
makes your
terms and conditions much worse the
dispute
doesn't seem for you to be just about
money it's about who you are of course
you know for myself um i'm a lower paid
worker in the council
and it's just is this the gratitude that
you get for putting your life on the
line during the pandemic to support the
community
tell hamlets councils say the new
contracts were only introduced after a
long period of consultation
the severance package they say remains
one of the most generous for council
workers in london
it prevents big payouts to high earners
and any money saved has been reinvested
into pay for staff
but this issue goes far beyond one
employer
research by the tuc earlier this year
found that nine percent of workers have
been told to reapply for their jobs
on worst terms and conditions since the
first lockdown in march last year
that figure doubles to 18 for young
people aged 18 to 24.
and workers from minority ethnic
backgrounds have been almost
twice as likely as white workers to have
faced fire and rehire
with 15 percent saying they've been
affected
and there's been widespread criticism of
the tactic including from the most
senior conservatives we believe that
using threats of firing and re-hiring is
unacceptable
as a negotiating tactic and there are
laws in place
uh to ensure that contractual uh
conditions uh
can't discriminate uh against people on
grounds of race or sexual
or disability now a former labour front
ventures trying to change the law
he's proposing a bill to clamp down on
fire and rehire
it's to stop managers intimidating the
workforce by saying
you're fired but if you want your back
job back in the morning
you have to sign these new terms and
conditions which are going to cut your
pay
cut your pension rights and and
going for the nuclear option right from
the beginning
what i want to see is proper
consultation
proper negotiation i want britain to be
the best place
for people to work not not to have this
bully boy tactics
i'm talking about some workers who were
told that this was going to be 12
000 pounds off their annual salary i'm
talking about
you know teachers who were told that it
was ripping up their pension rights
so we do need to see that this is
something that shouldn't be happening
and i'm i'm pleased actually that you
know if you speak
or listen to jacob reese morgan and
boris johnson
they both said that this is unacceptable
trouble is they've so far not been
willing to legislate
why do we need law on this surely
this is one where as you were saying we
get people
round the table try to engender some
trust
talk about it the issue is this no
employer believes that it is morally
right
simply to say to your workforce you're
fired
you accept 15 20 000 pounds
off your annual wage or you're out and
they don't there's no question about
that they know it's morally wrong
but because the law doesn't give them
any duty
to negotiate and to consult they don't
most of the employers who are in
disputes in this
situation tend to say the following
we're we've been faced with covid we're
faced with technological change and
disruption
we've got terms and conditions that have
lasted all 5
10 15 years in the end
we're left with a choice do we declare
redundancies
do we just collapse the company or do we
try
to get new terms many of the companies
who are doing this have actually made
record profits during the kogit pandemic
in response the government says we are
absolutely clear that using
fire and rehire as a negotiating tactic
is completely
unacceptable and we expect companies to
treat their employees
fairly if an employer needs to make
changes to an employee's contract
they must reach a formal agreement with
that worker or their representatives
we've asked acas to produce clearer and
more comprehensive guidance for business
a government commissioned review already
carried out by acas
found that there may be an increase in
fire and debris higher
when covered economic support measures
wind down
a process that began this month it's a
reminder that workers losing their jobs
hasn't been the only result of the
pandemic even for some of those still in
work
things are feeling very different
in response to our inquiry tower
hamlet's council sent us this statement
we have consulted extensively with our
staff since january 2019
and introduced revised terms and
conditions in july 2020
among the changes was a reduction to our
severance scheme
which remains one of the most generous
in london local
government the new terms and conditions
mean money has been diverted back into
improving pay for staff
working for the council no staff are on
worst conditions
or pay or have been dismissed as a
result of the changes
and we think they offer a fair deal for
our valued
staff now today is
nelson mandela day and it comes at a
time when many south africans may be
looking at the state of their nation
and wondering what the world's favorite
revolutionary would make of it
the jailing of former south african
president jacob
zuma earlier this month sparked
widespread riots and looting
with well over a hundred people killed
it's the worst
unrest seen in post-apartheid south
africa
so where does the rainbow nation go from
here i'm joined now by
quality campaigner and the eldest
daughter of nelson mandela dr makazui
mandela good morning dr mandela
what is the message of nelson mandela
day
the message of nelson mandela day is
about working together to address the
iniquities
to address poverty to do everything
as individuals to create a better life
for somebody
else and that's the message of nurse
mentality because no one person
no one organization can actually be able
to address
the social injustice the poverty that is
in society
you need a lot of people to come
together uh
individuals organizations government
to try and change this world to be a
better place for all
we're a long way from the
action that you're seeing some of it uh
extremely unpleasant we'll come to that
in a moment
but what would you like people uh out
here
in europe and north america to be doing
to celebrate this day
i think uh for me trevor as i look
around the world
um where we have uh and the coverage
which is plaguing a lot of people and as
just as i listen
a lot of people are losing their jobs
and
and there's a resurgence of racism
and ethnicism around the world i think
coverage has exhibited the iniquities in
society
and i think nelson mandela day is about
reminding
us of the challenges that are ahead of
us
and i think for me uh covered 19 has
shown that
humanity is capable of actually
helping each other to try and create
a better environment society and that if
we are not going to work together
and and hold hands
whether it's in the sort of rich north
there
and emerging south or the west we all
need to work together
basically i think that's the message of
of nelson mandela international day
well you you talked about the scourge of
covid and over the last year it has been
the greatest challenge to south africa
and across africa
actually infections have surged by about
43 percent in the space
of a week what does africa and south
africa
in particular need in order to be able
to meet that challenge
now i think the most important thing as
we have realized is that
we need vaccines and
because the rich uh west owner
has actually bought all the vaccines and
the emerging economies have better
looking of the vaccines
uh you know the social distancing i
think south africa did well
in the first phase of call it and to
some extent
a little bit better in the second wave
of the coming but
and that third wave is is becoming
more brutal on society mainly because
you know uh we have a lot of people who
are in in poverty
don't have the same access to to health
and
you know vaccines are very scarce around
the world
and so we are faced with
multiple challenges in south africa
and the one for africa
in terms of a vaccine and allowing some
of the
of the vaccines to be manufactured in
africa
can i turn to uh some more divisive
issues
um we've seen over the last year a
wave of concern anxiety protest
over racism a year ago the whole world
was talking about black lives matter
what do you think your father would be
saying about all of that were here live
today
i think my father would be repeating
what he said
when he was alive that the struggle is
not
actually complete and that we should not
tire
we should press on to fight racism with
everything
that we have in our might and and that
there needs to be
much more dialogue on on on racism
because it's plaguing the whole world
america uk um south africa we still
have a lot of uh after effects of
apartheid that we are killing
uh it's in europe i i think
my father would be saying we've got to
all put our heads together and find the
sketch of racism
until it ends let's turn to south africa
itself today i i was um on
television doing this job many years ago
when your father came out of poles more
prison
and i uh commentated on it with taboo
and becky who became his deputy
and the first president and i don't
think on that day
anybody imagine though we knew things
would be difficult
that south africa would be where it is
today question i really want to ask you
is
is this for the last 27 years the
movement that your father
and oliver tambo created the african
national
congress has been in government how much
of what is happening today
is the anc's responsibility
i would say all of which is actually the
responsibility of the aac
the anc seems to have forgotten why it
came into power
it came into power mainly
because it wanted to improve the
conditions and lives of black people
who have been impoverished they are
dignity taken away by the apartheid
regime
political freedom was never enough
my father knew it they knew it and
we cannot leave the economy that
supported apartheid
to be intact because there is no way
therefore
to redress the iniquities of the past
and address the conditions of the poor i
i mean if you look
at the conditions of the poor in south
africa
who are mainly black and it has not
improved
alexander when my death stage when he
came to join respect he's still the same
which has not improved
simple things like providing adequate
housing
water and clean services
has been something that this government
has failed actually our people in terms
to deliver
and so um what is happening right now
is squarely in their hands as my father
said
before with apartheid they cannot go on
forever
looking at peaceful means and the
government doesn't hear
those who are poor who have not
benefited from what i call the
post-apartheid dividend
have been poor for more than 300 years
their father their generations their
grandfather their great grandfather
how long should they wait until
conditions improve for them
nobody enter i want to assure you
wants to see south africa in the
situation of violence
but unless south africa squarely address
the issues of poverty and inequity
youth unemployment which is hovering at
about 74
south africa will see more of this
violence occurring
more and more dr mandela
thank you very much in indeed um i hope
today
uh is a good day for you at least thank
you
thank you very much trevor
as we've been discussing lockdown
restrictions in england will be lifted
tomorrow
good news from any business you may
think but a poll of business leaders
carried out by the chartered management
institute and shared
exclusively with this show has found
that half believe
the government is lifting restrictions
too quickly
39 believe it's happening at the right
pace
43 percent of managers said some staff
who
are currently working remotely will be
asked to return to the office
a quarter said they'd ask most staff
while only 13 will be asking all staff
to return
over three three-quarters of managers
will continue with covid19 safety
measures in the workplace
despite the lifting of restrictions
tomorrow only two percent will
not and there were concerns about the
impact of self-isolation
something we've been discussing this
morning 53 percent of managers were
concerned that the amount of staff
self-isolating will impact business
operations
46 weren't concerned well
to talk more about this we're joined by
the chief executive of the cmi
anne frank and frank um
half of respondents uh think that it's
all going too fast
why is there an explanation well i think
the explanation
is um quite apparent um as we know
cases are uh surging they're uh
they're um 50 000 and of course britain
now has
um the highest the third highest number
of cases in the world
um and equally we also know
that um many many many people are being
contacted i think it's up 46
week on week and asking to self-isolate
indeed um
the secretary of state for health for
example uh has contacted covet and the
prime minister's been asked
to um self-isolate so the disease is
still
very prevalent amongst us and it is
creating a lot of anxiety for
many people including many managers
it's odd though isn't it because
business leaders
are complaining on the one hand that uh
they're facing crisis because they can't
get everybody back to work
but half of them are now saying oh it's
all too quick
what what what should we really take
from that
well i think what we need to take from
this is that this pandemic
is um is complex there is not a one
size fits all solution and what
business leaders need to do is assess
their own situation carefully
and put in place measures that will
resonate for their workforce their
employees and their customers
so for example if you are in a workplace
that requires people to be on site such
as
a restaurant or a hotel then it makes
absolute perfect sense that you should
be able to
ask people to take daily lateral flow
tests
and you know be able to come into work
if those tests are negative
if you're in a workplace such as
services that
can work very productively remotely well
then
actually you should embrace the the more
flexible working policies and we know
many managers want
to continue flexible working
post-pandemic
um how do you think business managers
are going to managers are going to feel
this morning when they see that um as
far as one can make out prime minister
and chancellor can get on with their
business
come what may um but frankly
doesn't look like they'll be able to get
their people in and
doing the jobs in the way they would
like them to
yeah and that's where it's very
important that things like this pilot
scheme to give people the option to test
take a lateral flow test and go into
work it's very important that that's
extended to
businesses that require onsite presence
i think that the other thing i would say
is that it's really important that
employers
engage with their employees and set a
framework
so that people understand what their
employers are going to be doing and give
the employees a say in that
and and recognize there is not a
one-size-fits-all solution to
how we operate in covid um
just finally one of the most striking
things to me in these findings is it
uh two of the findings that suggest that
changes that
were forced by kobe may become permanent
three-quarters say they'll continue with
covered measures
and two-thirds say they expect some or
all of the staff
to work remotely do you think that's the
new normal
well absolutely i think what's a a good
thing about
the pandemic is forced us to reevaluate
our working practices and in many cases
modernize them
we know that 85 percent of managers
would like to continue with hybrid
working indeed 83
or working working hybrid at the moment
um and that actually
can be a more productive and more
enjoyable and a more inclusive way of
working
and so really we mustn't allow the
good changes in working practices to
slip back to the way it was we have a
great opportunity to create a better
workplace culture
and frank thank you very much indeed for
your time this morning
thank you that's it for today's show
which is the last one of this
series we're going to take a break for
the summer
but we'll be back before you know it in
early september before that we've got a
little encore for you trevor phillips
the take
is after the break we'll be going over
everything we've heard today
we'll be joined by a friend of the show
sam coates our deputy political editor
so don't go anywhere we'll be back in
just a few moments
[Music]
foreign